[Music]
this morning on the dish Toya Bodhi
she's a new orleans-based Chef cookbook
author and cultural Ambassador and she's
known for putting a unique Twist on
classic New Orleans style dishes and
taking the mystery and challenge out of
preparing them I got a taste and a
lesson on a visit to The Big Easy
now with my gumbo I always tell people
it's a six step gumbo when I first gave
that lesson my mother was like I don't
believe that but when I listed it I told
her I said all of the steps are minus
Young and the Restless you watching TV
look at your face all of that I think I
should be doing this all right come on
let's do it when it comes to making
gumbo Toya Bodhi has taken the
time-honored tradition and turned back
the clock once I mix the Trinity the
onion celery and the bell peppers into
the root of calm it down add it into the
cold stock wait for it to get hot the
New Orleans chef says Roux oil and flour
mixed with care is the longest part of
the process can I just say to all those
people who did not teach me how to cook
gumbo all those ears Booyah and let it
get crazy let it get crazy
why I grew from start to finish and
there you have it in under 30 minutes
instant gumbo here's to the room you
should be proud
and I made it in New Orleans how fitting
is that you talk a lot about
self-expression history
culture why is it important for you to
to impart these things so much of
society
over the year tries to wash it out and
to try to put you know particularly
black and brown people into these boxes
you know and they can't go outside them
and those boxes don't have the
representation of our culture that's the
only reason why gumbo is my favorite
dish to make because it's a raised to
riches meals started off on the tables
of the poor made its way to the tables
of the wealthy starting from scraps and
I look at everybody people fly here just
to get it it's also help because I
didn't trim the fat off it's part of her
winning strategy as she redefines
success in a city enamored with good
food I'm a private Chef for certain
clients and I'm talking in New Orleans
you can not only be a chef without a
restaurant but you could be a chef
without a restaurant and actually make
what we call guap which is a lot of
money like well yes no I've learned it's
money and then there's a lot of guap
what makes Bodhi popular is her
irresistible take on classic southern
cuisine showcased in her Cookbook
cooking for the culture I cooked a bunch
of things from my book I have the
collards with the sangria tomatoes and
Cornbread barbecue shrimp crab cakes
with Caper sauce and the baked mac and
cheese I really love this mac and cheese
not that mac and cheese that's
that's a killer this is a cardiac arrest
no I didn't say that
I recommend this if you're gonna do a
potluck and then when they go to dig in
it and they see the creaminess and then
they bite it and they say wait a minute
but it was the fried fish worthy of an
interruption and I made it pretty far in
the rounds all right what excuse me
that's some good catfish come on now I
don't eat catfish I know I was waiting
for you today but I'm being fair to you
here I'm happy you're a catfish because
I like it and in this spread the proof
was certainly in the pudding bread
pudding is white chocolate it's the
crunchy on the inside that's just the
stickiness from the white chocolate the
sugar all of that because I chop it up
real fine and I mix it all through and I
put chunks in the middle I know if I do
shrimp etouffee in the past few years
Bodhi has garnered appreciation on the
cooking competition circuit bringing her
signature Flair you're gonna love it so
swipe up I would notice everyone who was
Southern changing who they are
to be on camera and then I just started
being tired of it I'm not changing my
hair anymore I'm not changing my nails
I'm not changing my no because we embody
something really good here A New Orleans
native she remembers times when both of
her parents worked more than one job to
make ends meet dinner will be made
before we left for school because we
could not afford it at all to have fast
food or even boxed things this was from
scratch
Bodhi started cooking professionally
about the age of 15 at a local store but
that same year her life took an
unexpected turn when she learned she was
pregnant literally my sweet 16 birthday
was in Planned Parenthood but I'm
telling you when that girl her name is
heaven and when I looked at the
definition that is exactly what happened
to our lives how you doing hello that's
your mommy
[Music]
Christmas has changed everybody was
happy around the house it was like the
house was Lively
it was just a everything changed for the
better like after she came
one of those things was how Bodhi
channeled her creativity and this is
where you got your start yes yes I
started out poetry on this stage Open
Mic nights on Tuesdays and it was on
from there making a name for herself as
a poet I saw my life changing with each
read with each time I just memorized
something and I committed to it I
started seeing my life like flip and
mold Bodie met her husband Chris online
and he helped her build her brand I want
everyone to feel comfortable with
cooking Ten Years Later the couple is
still going strong two girls two boys
oldest just entered the master's program
oh
so what I'm doing here it's that energy
body brings to her cooking and her
Mission I'm gonna be as Unapologetic as
possible for whatever little girls need
to come behind it who need book deals
whatever women decide I'm 56. I think
I'm gonna do that book I've always
wanted to do do it
pay her too and from now on she says
there's no holding back do you have any
plans we don't know about
I plan on seeing what develops after
this book there's parts of the journey
that I can't know until I get there
so I'm just going to focus on showing up
on time the rest of this year
and she's ready to take on whatever life
has in store I mean she is what we call
in The Big Easy naturally knowledge
everything about her her life taking it
on the way it has and much like the
hurricane here by you be careful there
are two kinds of rums in this puppy but
she is she she packs a punch I'm very
she's one of those people you meet and
you just you you just feel Glee for I
don't even know that you have to meet or
just watching that I did absolutely
loved her and I want that mac and cheese
yes oh listen I want the mac and cheese
the catfish did not have that metally
tape
very good Michelle thank you very much
thank you cheers cheers